les terriens robes en soie l'intérieur
nous sommes toujours en compagnie de
pierre arditi
de thierry mariani
eglee plenel
et nous accueillons notre invité du
samedi 20 heures ce soir olivia chaumont
bonsoir
alors les biens jusqu'à 50 ans vous avez
été un homme marié sous le nom d'olivier
vous dirigiez une grosse agence
d'architecturé à paris vous étiez membre
du grand orient de france mais à 50 ans
submergé par votre trans identité jusqu
alors étouffé vous avez fini par céder à
votre désir de devenir femme
mois contre une autre histoire à 20
heures
[Musique]
olivier un bon soir vous êtes né le 30
octobre 1950 à meudon sous le nom
d'olivier dans une famille de cinq
enfants père ingénieur dans la marine
mère femme au foyer vous dites
génétiquement j'étais un garçon j'avais
des jouets de garçons on met du quai
comme un garçon mais moi je me sentais
attirée par le monde des filles depuis
toujours il n'ya pas un moment donné on
dirait qu'on a cet état de choses
bizarres oui alors en fait vous dites je
suivais mes frères à contre coeur pour
éviter qu'on se moque de moi nous
assigne finalement le monde de la
masculinité quand on naît garçon est de
dire qu'on aura on a plutôt envie
d'aller dans un autre bah ça c'est
s'exposer effectivement des à des
railleries ou des choses comme ça donc
on ne dit pas donc on reste dans son
qu'est ce qu'on fait on dit c'est nul on
dit si bavarde ici mais voilà ce qui est
terrible c'est que pour parfaire votre
image de garçon au collège vous mettez
au rugby
c'est terrible oui c'est vrai vous avez
vraiment donner le change
alors vous avez des petites copines nous
dit j'étais sûrement plus romantique que
les autres et ça plaisait aux filles
évidemment alors c'est donc des années
60 que vous commencez à vouloir être une
femme mais à l'époque évidemment c'est
absolument impensable
l'homosexualité est encore une maladie
mentale et transsexualité je crois que
le mot n'existe même pas à l'époque
ouais c'est quelque chose qu'on est
maintenant plus votre père était
militaire et gaullistes donc ça
arrangeait pas les choses dont vous
décidez de mettre un couvercle sur vos
pulsions voilà alors après le bac vous
voulez devenir pilote de ligne mais un
problème d'oreille interne vous interdis
cette profession et vous devenez
architectes et finalement vous avez une
bonne vie à ce moment là vous êtes
étudiant à paris dans les années 70 sexe
drogue et rock'n'roll
mais oui ce furent de belles années 70
channel de la femme tout à fait bien sûr
voilà puis vous arranger de votre
problème quoi là vous êtes toujours
effectivement un garçon après dix ans
d'études vous travaillez à marseille
hélas le temps vous semble long parce
que vous vous retrouvez un petit peu
isolé seul face à vous même et vos
pulsions identitaires redouble et c'est
là que vous découvrez l'existence de
bambi et coccinelles qui étaient des
artistes de transsexuels à l'époque et
vous vous dites c'est possible je vais
le faire quoi la france entière admire
sss et de
ces deux femmes
ça m'a fait comprendre que oui c'est
possible c'est possible faire ça mais là
vous rencontrez des transsexuels à
marseille donc rue curiol qui est la rue
un peu chaudes de la ville et vous
comprenez en fait que pour les
transsexuels c'est le show biz ou la rue
oui j'ai renoncé
s'est scellée seule personne vers qui
j'ai pu aller à l'impôt pour trouver de
l'information c'est qu'est-ce que j'ai
découvert à ce moment là ce sont
effectivement des femmes oui mais qu'est
ce transsexuels qui se prostituaient
gagner de l'argent qui était totalement
dépressives voire suicidaires pour
certaines donc j'ai dit non ça c'est pas
possible tu veux vivre ma vie mais pas
ce prix - entier le couvercle sur les
pulsions toujours c'était toute votre
vie en 1981 vous avez 31 ans vous
remontez à paris pour ouvrir une agence
d'architecturé vous mettez à votre
compte rapidement les premiers contrats
tombe non seulement en france mais à
l'étranger ça marche et vous devenez un
patron comme les autres et là vous
devenez francs-maçons pourquoi
c'est un engagement c'est un engagement
personnel j'avais toujours dit que
maîtresse aucune bannière sous aucun des
temps d'un finalement c'était très
confortable de rester chez soi dans ses
rangs dans son confort politique et puis
des circonstances étaient les
européennes et c'est une des premières
années où le front national avait fait
un score très élevé mais c'était comme
un
catalyseur dans ma décision je suis que
là je pouvais pas rester dans mon
fauteuil je fasse quelque chose
ensuite vous marier
oui et les années passent la pression
monte à l'intérieur de vous et un jour
après 50 ans de comédie vous comprenez
que pouvait plus lutter quoi il faut que
olivier deviennent olivia au risque de
perdre tout ce que vous aviez construit
je prends l'image souvent d'une vague
qui vient frapper devant plus souvent
sur indy et puis
la dga rompu randonnée pour des raisons
tout à fait inconnu et
à ce moment là je me suis dit que cette
vague là
emporte moi ok alors là vous vous
laissez aller à votre féminité vous vous
épiler les sourcils vous venez de plus
en plus androgyne en fait les gens
disent rien parce que ils disent c'est
un artiste quoi donc voilà il fait comme
il veut voilà c'est ça participe et du
métier que vous faisiez en fait créatif
quoi oui dans un premier temps c'était
pas si anormal que ça voilà oui là vous
prenez les hormones qui sont ordonnés
par un psychiatre parce qu'à l'époque
sont encore considérés comme une maladie
mentale c'est là qu'on commence à
comprendre ce que c'est que d'engager un
parcours sur deux
sur la trans identité et ce sont les
deux éléments de la vie que la société
qu'on rencontre d'un côté le médecin
tout le corps médical et l'autre côté
plus tard on le verra le corps juridique
oui on ne peut pas vivre ça trans
identité indépendamment de la société
com
l'homosexualité qu'on peut vivre
finalement de façon tout à fait anonyme
et discrète nous ne pouvons pas
auprès les hormones au bout de quelques
mois votre poitrine gros si votre voix
change votre visage se transforme je
dirais heureusement que votre père n'est
pas là pour voir ça parce que ça aurait
été chaude oui je pense que
mais c'était un homme tolérant je pense
qu'il aurait finalement accepté la chose
en tous les cas delattre maire à
l'époque refuse de vous appeler olivia
pendant un premier temps il salua était
difficile alors là votre couple vole en
éclats évidemment j'imagine que votre
femme voyant sa demande avait voulu
divorcer voilà votre business décline
aussi vous faites moins d'affaires à ce
moment là quand on engage une transition
faut savoir qu'on est complètement le
concentrer sur ceux sur cette
transformation qui nous qui vous prend
qui vous prend complètement
effectivement c'est au détriment de tas
d'autres choses on sait qu'il va y avoir
des pertes des pertes au niveau du
travail des personnels au niveau de la
famille des amis les choses comme ça on
sait qu'il va y avoir de la casse oui on
y va quand même pas vous décidez d'en
finir avec olivier parce qu'en fait
quelle que soit votre apparence sur
votre carte d'identité il a toujours
écrit olivier donc quand vous donnez vos
papiers c'est horrible on vous dit mme
attendez c'est pas vous et ça c'est
olivier quoi donc à un moment ça devient
invivable on est déjà dans une apparence
féminine on commence à vivre le genre
vers lequel on veut année c'est la même
chose pour des femmes qui deviennent des
hommes il y en a autant et on est
éternellement confronté à devoir
décliner son identité à la poste on vous
demande la procuration de votre mari
la carte vitale pour nos billets d'avion
une voiture enfants passe son temps à
décliner son identité donc on est en
permanence racheter dans la masculinité
voilà qu'on veut fuir un beau défi
d'aller au bout vous décidez de changer
de sexe alors le plus sûr c'est la
thaïlande
10 voyages organisés voilà ça coûte
15000 euros all inclusive tout compris
quoi on arrive là-bas l'aéroport est
quelqu'un qui vous attend à bangkok et
qui vous amène dans une clinique quoi
oui la veille de l'opération va mais
j'avais plus peur de l'opération que du
changement de sexe en fait ces peurs
moins sûr ça dure six heures c'est une
opération très dangereuse donc alors
l'opération consiste évidemment
l'ablation du pénis et des testicules
puis la construction d'un vagin et d'un
clitoris ils savent le faire
alors voilà donc on vous montrera des
photos de l'intervention vous dites ça
ressemble à un meccano démonter et j'en
ai vu une save a suffi effectivement se
dit heureusement que le chirurgien part
pas en vrille ouais alors quand vous
voyez dans le miroir vous ressentez un
immense apaisement c'est fait et vous
retourner en france où vous devenez
olivia si je dis bien dire que pas de
changement de sexe pas ce changement de
papier et là vous donnez vraiment olivia
je suis pas devenu audi vient comme ça
sur plan de l'état civil
tout de suite parce que il faut faire
une demande c'est très compliqué et
c'est là que dans les critères qui sont
imposés pour changer l'identité on vous
oblige avoir eu l'opération et ça c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut bien comprendre
que justement les personnes dont je
parlais tout à l'heure qui ne désire pas
être opéré on va les obliger à être
opéré ce que ça et quand il s'agit d'une
femme qui devient un homme où
l'opération est quasiment impossible la
nature on la copie pas comme ça alors là
on leur demande de ceux d'autres
stérilisés oui pour pouvoir changer de
prénom c'est vraiment des pratiques
personnellement il se qualifierait de
barbare quand même
imposé à quelqu'un la stérilisation pour
changer de prénom alors ce qui est
extraordinaire dans votre histoire c'est
que sur le plan sexuel vous retrouvé vos
préférences les femmes doivent y ait eu
des rapports et des femmes toute votre
vie et vous donne et lesbiennes
sais que je reviens de la france mais
avec ses attentes le soir 1 voilà mes
bonnes consciences et l'opération est
tellement bien réussi que vous
connaissez des orgasmes ça dépend du
partenaire oui une fois vous êtes
justement il faut que j'ai fait l'amour
avec un homme
et lui dit je ne m'était encore jamais
senti aussi femmes évidemment ça s'est
bien passé
non ce sont un peu un peu idiote à fond
à mon âge quand même alors cette
extraordinaire en fait c'est que vous
voulez rester au grand orient de france
sauf que le grand orient il n'y a pas de
femmes venez en fait la première femme
du grand orient de france voilà où est
ce qu'ils n'arrivaient pas à régler et
venant de l'extérieur puisque les
effectivement les femmes n'avaient pas
ne pouvait pas rentrer au grand orient
c'est sale c'est venu par l'intérieur il
ya eu un cas le mien qui s'est posée
qu'à poser un problème a dit j'ai dit
que j'étais pas un problème j'étais un
être humain et qu'il fallait trouver des
solutions humaines a fait ça ce qui a
été fait finalement est ce que
maintenant les voir d'autres femmes au
grand orient de france maintenant c'est
possible mais donc c'est une avancée
terrible vous avez fait du féminisme
voilà
il ya un truc aussi qui doit être
intéressant c'est quand vous étiez un
homme chef de votre agence d
architecture
quand vous disiez un truc tout le monde
obéit c est ce que c'est pareil quand on
est une femme
ça c'est quelque chose qu'on peut pas
imaginer avant quand on est on sait
qu'on va arriver sur l'autre rive et on
sait pas ce qu'on va trouver la bonne on
imagine ont le rêve mais quand on arrive
on sait pas et là j'ai découvert société
que d'être une fin la wii dans un monde
qui ait d'autres aujourd'hui et
maintenant quand on me demande ce que je
fais je dis je suis architecte ah oui
vous êtes architecte d'intérieur ah oui
oui décorateur départ raté
une fois on ne peut pas être comme ça
avoir assez fait
vous êtes bien placé pour voir ce que
c'est le monde vu des femmes quoi ah oui
ça se voit que il n'y en pas beaucoup de
choses à faire beaucoup de choses à
gagner et que ce qu'on entend n'est pas
faux alors aujourd'hui sa valeur votre
vie vous êtes contents mais ça y est
maintenant c'est réglé en place doit
livrer votre maman vous appelle olivia
absolument les cadeaux qu'elle m'a fait
tout va bien oui j'ai absolument aucun
regret un an qu est ce que vous
regrettez pas de ne pas l'avoir fait
plus tôt à 6 a certainement oui bien sûr
c'est le seul regret mais bon c'était
c'est impossible pour moi dans les
conditions qui étaient les miennes à mon
époque aujourd'hui ces diagnostics est
beaucoup plus tôt il faut savoir que des
parents peuvent être confrontés à ça à
16 17 ans un enfant une fille et un
garçon peuvent
présenté ce désir d'être dans l'autre
jour ça peut être
accompagner et non plus comme avant où
on cherchait à guérir oui absolument
nous guérir les malades mentaux que nous
étions et nous faire une place dans la
société car il faut absolument qu'elle
lois qui encadrent
ça aujourd'hui ça n'existe pas ça se
perd des politiques vont se saisir enfin
mariani demain matin il dépose la loi la
forêt
de vie un mot formidable tu allais
je trouve quand les propos d'olivier ya
un calme et une sérénité finalement
beaucoup de lucidité très bonne auto
analyse oui c'était là où elle devait
arriver
hier vous deviez avoir beaucoup de
charme comme homme et vous avez un
infini grand femmes non je vous dis est
d'autant plus maniable d'autant plus
troublante pour moi que vous ressemblez
un tableau de mon père qui s'appelle la
péruvienne
j'ai la passion que ce tableau qui
m'accompagne depuis mon enfance est
animé depuis un quart d'heure
le chianti mesdames messieurs voilà et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
hardy tube abonnez vous je m'étais un
peu ce bleu